In this lesson, I want you to think
about computations that, on the surface,
don't appear to have any parallelism.
In the process, you'll learn what I
think are some really neat tricks
about how to extract parallelism
when it's not obvious how to do so.
As a teaser, I want you to
imagine the following scenario.
Suppose you're standing in an absurdly
long line in a very large room.
The room is completely dark,
so you can't see anything.
Maybe you're waiting in line at
the registrar's office to pick up your
OMSCS degree.
You ask yourself, how many people
are in front of me in this line?
And, to find out,
you can only talk to the person right
in front of you or right behind you.
That's not so hard, you say.
After all you're young,
smug, and smart, and
you know that the first person knows
that she is the first person, so
she can turn to her neighbor behind
her and say, hey, I'm number one.
That person now knows that
he must be number two.
So he pays it forward or,
in this case, backwards and
tells his position to the next person,
and it goes on and on like this.
Now that's a lovely and
simple solution to this problem, but
suppose there are 10 million
people in this line.
If it takes 1 second to do
an information exchange,
then it's going to take about 10 million
people x 1 second / 3,600 seconds
per hour / 24 hours per day,
or 115 days for
the last person in line to learn
that he or she is number 10 million.
That person,
in nearly four months' time,
could have probably finished
a whole other OMSCS degree.
Now, this scenario is an analogy for
a well-known problem in parallel
algorithms called list ranking.
You are given a singly linked list and
a pointer to the head.
What you want to compute is
the position of every node in the list.
Sequentially it's trivial to do, but
if you have multiple processors,
can you use parallelism to do it faster?
You might want to pause the video for
a second and
see if you can think of a way,
and unless you already know how,
I bet you'll have a very
hard time doing so.
To get an efficient parallel scheme,
what you might find is that every thing
you've been told about the best way to
store a linked list is completely wrong.
File it under lies my
other teachers told me.
So, without further adieu,
let's see if we can undo a couple years
of bad sequential computing habits.